Thì hôm nay, tôi nghĩ tôi nên sông ngày bị bụng thông nghi một cho biết
ông đã tiến hành có cuộc đẹp đầm với lãnh đạo thay lãnh và càng phù tría
giảm ngăn con thẳng biến dổi dưới 2 nước lâu thang
ông cho biết thêm đã giận được những tiến hiệu tích cực sầu có cuộc gọi
và tiến rằng tiến hình 2 nước sẽ ổn
một con chức đã trang cho biết
ông Trump cũng đã chăng đồ về tiến mà laisia để cập nhật tiến trình ngoại giao
laisia là nước tường của hợp về Mỹ trong việc thúc đầy thảo thật luôn bánh
dựa bằng cực và phương đúng bánh hồi thầm bây
sau được giao trành khiến đình 5 người trên mạng và khoảng 18,000 người phải xe tán
Washington có cuộc đầy lãnh đổi tắt thành chốt trong lực truy trí đổi thuật của
chức đó các thẳng thẳng thẳng khai lãnh càng phù tría bùng lên cho lại trong tần này
khi bằng cực đình trí thảo thật lưu bánh giòn Mỹ, Malaysia lãnh trung ra
và yêu cầu phân ông bánh xin lỗi vì kai thêm mình tại khu vực biến dưới chẳng chấp dẫn hành dốc
khiến 2 bình xí viết thương, các phù tría bắt bỏ gạo buộc và nổi rằng thay lãnh không phải quan
và đăng này chẳng biệt bản giòn mởi tạm biệt sĩ, công buổi chia đam bị tạm giữ
chẳng chấp lãnh thổ dành hành dốc đã kéo dành yêu thập kì giòn không phân định được bình dưới
và thường xe tạm đột đột. Trời đến tối, người bùng thông nghi một
cả thái lãnh và công buổi chia đều chưa công bố việc khôi phục cơ truyền nông bánh
phọc mở lại cân đổi thải nào sau có cuộc điện đàm của tổng thống Mỹ Đồ Nà Trong